Now the first mesh optimization I'd like to talk about has to deal with system units. Now Unreal Engine 5 uses
centimeters for its unit of measurement, so one Unreal unit equals one centimeter.
The reason that it's so important to make sure that your
digital content creation tool, or your DCC, is set to
centimeters is so that we can avoid any scaling issues between your DCC and your Unreal Engine 5
project. Now here we have the system units of 3D Studio Max showing that we have this set to centimeters, and
while you can
scale your
assets on export, it's better to make sure that you're actually creating them
using centimeters, as this unit of measurement is going to have a lot of effects on how things work in the engine. For example,
importing a really large mesh and then scaling it down could have all types of
repercussion for other systems such as collision, physics, and even nanite.
This is why it's best practice to make sure that everything uses centimeters as your default unit of measurement,
unless your pipeline requires some type of
specific reason for using another unit of measurement.